[Music]
x-men first class uh people love the
film it's interesting you played uh
beast but you played him younger so
kelsey grammer's character you played
him as a younger version i would think
that'd be difficult as an actor because
you sort of have to play a young kelsey
grammer because the role has already
been established
exactly what they matthew vaughn kind of
wanted me to do they you know
kelsey did a great job and so he was
like just watch kelsey and do what he
did yeah so i watched hours of frasier i
would sit there and just watch and
frasier continually i never seen it
before right um and i'd sit there and
and that would be my thing to kind of
get into the accent a little bit i'd
walk around being like niles niles
probably want you just to yeah watch him
as beast not frasier that's probably
that's completely the wrong answer i've
watched hours of cheers and i think i've
got the down the essence of the
character you also you tried a lot of
voices at first for the character
including is this true for the audition
you tried stewie you tried it griffin
yeah really yeah that was an odd one
where where matthew said uh yeah and
just just do one in stewie griffin's
voice and i was like
that's odd yeah uh but i gave it a shot
i mean
hopefully that tape never comes out
if you do it now we'll have the tape
yeah can we just you want to yeah just
here a second it's your stewie yeah come
on
okay so
hey hey what's up big guy
you want to want a soda how about that
that's
why would he ask you but what kind of
directors asking you to do it you know
now do it as minnie mouse i mean how is
that how is that helping you
they were probably just having a laugh i
feel that's the thing they do in
auditions sometimes that's as they just
see how far they can push you and what
you'll do for a job yeah now put on this
little girl's dress and try it we think
that would help you know about that as
well i saw that tape yeah